le suspense aura duré quatre jours mais
ce moment les démocrates l'attendait
depuis très exactement quatre ans moins
un jour
donald trump a été congédié joe biden
deviendra le 46e président des états
unis
nos journalistes sont aux quatre coins
du pays pour ne rien manquer de ce jour
historique d'abord azem
le président-élu prononcera le plus
important discours de sa carrière sans
aucun doute ce soir à 20 heures il devra
trouver les mots pour apaiser l'unir se
présentent exactement pascal ans et
c'est un pays divisé donc ici on est un
peu dans le campement de joe biden à
wilmington devant le château où il va
livrer un discours ce soir un discours
on s'attend il va essayer de réconcilier
la nation il a déjà dit qu'au fond lui
veut diriger tous les américains
même ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour lui
donc c'est un discours extrêmement
attendu
il savait tout au long de la journée
essayait vraiment eu un soupir de
soulagement ici un grand ouf général on
sent que les américains pendant quatre
ans là ce sont retenus n'ont pas
beaucoup parlé et qu'aujourd'hui enfin
ils exposent leur joie ce cas évidemment
ce cheval des partisans démocrates qui
sont vraiment très heureux aujourd'hui
encensé était extrêmement tendue et vous
l'avais dit c'était un suspense qui a
duré très longtemps
on écoute un extrait des réactions qu'on
a pu obtenir aujourd'hui résume alors à
pouvoir le partenaire du café on voit
qu'il a de quoi les cheminots pas
d'effet beau témoignage rapidement il
devra mettre en place jean bart 10 en
équipe de transition
absolument il ya un groupe de travail
qui va travailler sur cette pandémie
vous savez qu'à 130 mille nouveaux cas
juste aujourd'hui il a donc évidemment
il revient un groupe de travail là
dessus
dans notre championnat pas vraiment
gérer cette pandémie là là on va avoir
vraiment des experts et va y avoir un
plan national donc il va en parler ce
soir et joe biden pascal entre dans
l'histoire et va voir 78 temps là le 20
novembre
ça va être le président le plus âgé à
entrer à la maison blanche est
évidemment kamala harris aussi ça va
être la première dame vice-présidente
des etats-unis également la première
femme sa mère est indienne son père est
d'origine jamaïcaine donc la première
femme issue de la communauté ethnique
qui entre en fonction également donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a pu entendre aussi
c'est le leader démocrate du sénat
monsieur chômeurs qui a voulu prendre un
peu le pouls de ce qui s'est passé à
brooklyn
je vous invite à écouter un extrait
[Applaudissements]
les instincts d'euros on espère donc
voilà donc en fait c'est un peu le
sentiment que les gens ont ici et vous
savez quand il parle de la récession
économique il ya quand même 20 millions
de chômeurs ici aux etats unis
donc ce ne sera pas une tâche facile
pour john dryden en tout cas aujourd'hui
c'est l'heure est vraiment à la
célébration sont heureux c'est vraiment
y déguste les gens ici savoure cette
victoire de joe biden ils ont très hâte
d'écouter son discours qui va être dans
quelques heures la à 20h heure d'ici là
merci à des valeurs à plus tard frédéric
trechsel a fait aussi dans les rues de
washington devant la maison blanche
aussi bien sûr évidemment pascal et ça
faisait des mois qu'on n'avait pas vu
washington comme ça sortir de cette
torpeur a accablé par la pandémie avec
des rues vides et là aujourd'hui ça a
complètement changé
écoutez le ciel était bleu les y avait
pas de nuages les démocrates sont sortis
c'est ce qui nous disait regardez comme
il fait beau c'est un nouveau jour c'est
une nouvelle ère qui commence faut
savoir pascal que washington s'est
démocrates mais à plus de 93% ça fait
deux fois que les gens de washington ne
vote pas pour donald trump
alors là pas du tout et aujourd'hui
c'était la fête c'était vraiment les on
sortait les casseroles on sentait les
claques sont un peu à l'image de la
campagne de joe biden on sortait les
drapeaux américains les drapeaux de
baden harris c'était vraiment quelque
chose de très fort ici dans cette
capitale et on se trouve juste en face
de la maison blanche toujours habité ici
par évidemment donald trump et le
message était fort ici de ces gens-là de
tous les âges de toutes les races de
toutes les confessions de venir de faire
l'effort de se déplacer dans cette dans
cette rue
enfin profiter quelques dizaines de
milliers à avoir fait ce déplacement ce
jour qu'il qualifie ici à washington
19 mais il faut quand même le signifier
on est en fin de journée et le contre on
parle toujours refuse toujours de
concéder la victoire à dubaï dit oui et
ça n'est pas prêt d'arriver non plus
écoutés donald trump lui-même en fait
quelques dizaines de minutes avant que
les réseaux américains annoncent la
victoire de joe biden et bien il avait
quitté la maison blanche
il était en fait au à son golf à
stirling en virginie pas très loin d'ici
il a passé à peu près une bonne partie
de la journée là bas et il est revenu un
peu après 3 heures à bord de sa de son
cortège de sa limousine donc il est de
retour ici à la maison blanche mais pas
de questions de concéder du tout il ya
toutes ces troupes sa horde d'avocats
qui continue d'essayer de se battre
devant les tribunaux pour faire annuler
ici et là différentes choses et roddy
giuliani évidemment en avait gros sur le
coeur aujourd'hui à l'endroit justement
des réseaux tels américains qui ont
annoncé la victoire alors que lui dicte
et c'est pas fini on va se battre
jusqu'au bout
voici un extrait de son point de presse
et voilà donc une autre journée sans
vraiment de nouvelles de monsieur tron
face caméra on attend évidemment
probablement d'autres tweets dans la
soirée ça ne devrait pas être très
positif
vous vous en doutez étant donné la
situation actuelle pour lui et son parti
en tout cas on sait quand il est en venu
de sa partie de golf parce qu'on l'a vu
rentrer à la maison blanche sur une
photo merci beaucoup frédéric et je vous
dis aussi à plus tard philippe vous
aident à philadelphie en pennsylvanie
les tacles et à qui les démocrates de
dire merci merci merci aujourd'hui parce
que c'est l'état qui a donné la victoire
à joba est donné c'est toujours on
l'entend la faible dans les rues c'est
la fête dans les rues aux quatre coins
de la ville que ce soit devant la classe
de la liberté dans des endroits
résidentiel mais les gens sont
spontanément rassemblés devant le centre
des congrès où l'on a compté les votes
est ici devant l'hôtel de ville sur la
mythique rue broadway où les gens sont
venus avec des tambours des percussions
de rue vous le voyez il ya énormément de
téléphones cellulaires du monde et se
documenter ce moment qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y avait énormément de
personnes affluaient les fille qui
attendait depuis quatre ans une ville
qui est fortement démocrate dans un bar
a causé la surprise il ya quatre ans
en portant la pennsylvanie et il a passé
les dernières semaines à s'attaquer à la
pennsylvanie star était particulièrement
à la ville de philadelphie
ce qu'il faisait à ses partisans dans le
genre c'est vous allez voir ils vont
essayer de nous voler l'élection à
philadelphie tu les défis en processus
électoral pourri corrompus non ce qu'on
voyait dans la dans la rue en ce moment
ce sont les joies qui exclut les gens
qui expriment la joie d'avoir fait un
pied mais spectaculaire d'europe ils se
soient ici que ça a également été le
point de bascule ce matin car les
raisons on déclarait que je m'adonne à
vega
j'ai rencontré des partisans dans ce
genre il y en avait quand même dans la
rue
et aussi des partisans de joe madden
quelques instants ce matin après qu'ont
annoncé la victoire de tours bad
avant et depuis boost apte à l'honneur
et à la technique
ces deux marques qui pour aller changer
quelqu'un d'entier nantes et l'important
prix honni pour appeler à tout report ou
5490 pour 2009